hey everybody
and welcome to an incredible
wild ride with stevo i honestly don't
know how we got this week's guest
well that's a lie i do know because he
told us
he's a fan i mean wow what an honor
and as self-made billionaires go
this guy's the coolest of them all i
think so let's dive in
okay you want to just dive right into it
let's go okay
we've got the the dallas mavericks blue
i'm down let's go
all right i like it here we go this is
how we do it
ladies and gentlemen mark cuban
yeah dude what's up guys
i want you to meet my co-host scott
randolph right here hey mark
randolph how you doing and up at the
front of the van we've got the gorgeous
paul briskey
hey mark how are you what's up gorgeous
hey what's happening exactly dude
we're all piled into a van this is how
we do it it's our gimmick it's the wild
ride podcast
yep and we have a lot of fun my first
question is how did we get you
you asked right i'm i'm a big steve o
fan man forever and so it's like when i
had the opportunity it was like yes
absolutely ah man i just i can't tell
you how much i appreciate it and
you know i i say that a little bit in
jest but uh
but i was just really kind of curious
like where you know like
and and here we are dude so my next
question
now that we have you now that we're
doing this we've got this podcast we're
gonna
upload it you know before we upload it
and make it public
should we sell it as an nft absolutely
why wouldn't you
you know why why not right the worst
people could do is just ignore it
but then again you might out people
people maybe people come in and spend
69.9
million dollars how do you know he won't
wow jesus okay so it's like that huh
people are just spending money on nft's
left and right well right but
my question was uh is the
putting it up for sale is that something
you do before this becomes public
or after it becomes public you would do
it after after i mean
unless you were given doing some
giveaway or something and there was some
like game of chance or gamification of
it you would just put it
up there and you know just say to people
like there's only 10 of these being made
and you're the only ones that have
actual ownership of the wild ride nft
and so what's it worth to you you know
or you could put a price on
it and say like one each because one
each doesn't sound like a lot but that's
two grand man and when you think about
it
that's why they price it and eat that's
like poker chips you know
it's like you don't think it's real
money you just push the money in i'm all
in
i'm sorry you said a one e one e yeah
ethereum
and so when they price these things
because what an nft
is is it's memorialized
it's like a certificate that's on this
thing called a blockchain the ethereum
blockchain
and since it's on the ethereum
blockchain they price it in
the currency of ethereum so you know
there you go all right now you know nfts
are where it's at
i've got to just admit i still don't
quite
understand it you know like but for real
though steve for real
like taking some of your original
moments and things that nobody has ever
seen
and making them available as collectors
items because think about all the [ __ ]
that you've signed
all the stuff that's been auctioned all
the times you've taken pictures
you know we're done like meet and greets
or cameos
all those things are collectibles that
are physical
you know or in real life so that you
have to you have to be there and do
stuff but
think of nfts as digital collectibles
right
and so anything that you can make
digital because
each each nft can be made to be unique
just as a one-off
you know when people people who collect
stuff you know steve o's stuff they're
gonna want it
and so that's what that's why people buy
like people had a ton of fans right
and so he's had fans for years he's been
doing it for years
and he would sell them as digital art it
just wasn't an nft it just wasn't
memorialized
you know with a certificate on the
blockchain but you could do the exact
same thing man it's just
it's crazy it's right now is the time
would you take that nft and cash it out
or keep it in ethereum
i would keep it in ethereum wow wow
do you like that does ethereum being the
currency that is used for
nfts does that is that gonna help
ethereum grow in value as well
exactly right that's exactly why i
wouldn't sell it so all the ethereum
that i've gotten um for nfts and for
stuff i bought or whatever sold rather
um i've kept forever so it's ethereum
been very very good to me
all right but at the same time like you
got you got to think about it like kids
like and i'm talking like gen
z right their their most valuable [ __ ]
is on their phone so they're used to
thinking about
everything being valuable everything
digital is what's of value
think about it like when you have a kid
that runs out of storage on their phone
right that's like the worst thing ever
you know it's like now you got to delete
something from your phone
to make room on your phone and everybody
freaks out
kids freak out right and so kids you
know
that they're not old enough to have a
house maybe they have a car
and they have their their favorite
clothes for their you know in the
favorite places
they've gone for their instagram
pictures but everything of value to them
is digital
now think about every autograph that's
ever been auctioned every picture you
took that's ever been auctioned
that really became a digital picture
anyways and what nfts allow you to do it
just makes it easier to buy and sell but
here's the really cool part
and why nfts are really blowing up like
if you sell
a picture a physical picture you never
get paid again so
you know like when you have a show all
those dudes that are out there trying to
get you to sign
[ __ ] yeah and they say it's for the sick
kid when you know they're going to put
it on ebay
right when that [ __ ] sells and resells
you get nothing
when you sell as an nft when you set it
up it's a process called minting
there's a little box you typically fill
in and it's called royalties
and that allows you to get paid every
time it's resold
wow that's what makes this [ __ ] crazy
right that's what makes it
so different than anything else so like
i did a little test
i took a picture of me walking into our
arena getting ready to work out
and i just wanted to learn because i'm a
tech geek right and so i made 20 of them
that i sold for 25 bucks each thinking
no one's gonna pay 25 bucks for this
[ __ ] picture right
but i just wanted to learn and so as i'm
filling it all out
there's a little section called royalty
and i put in 15 i'm like what what the
hell right if someone buys it and
resells it
and then i tweeted about it and bam
start selling not only did it sell but
it started reselling
and reselling and the price keeps on
going up and i'm collecting 15 percent
every single time so do you second guess
yourself for going in uh at just fifteen
percent
like that the next time you do it do you
do a larger percent oh yeah
absolutely i did i did 20 and i tried
one at 25.
25 kind of puts a limit on it because
people don't reach
it's harder to resell right because the
people who are going to pay more might
not make
as much but um it's crazy just crazy
so if all that stuff that your mom wants
you to throw away
your girlfriend or wife or whatever
wants you to throw away you take a
picture of it
you put it on make it an nft and you let
all your fans you tweet about it you put
it on social media you put it on wild
ride
hey y'all if you really are fired up
about the wild ride
see this this is the pink slip for this
for you know
for for this vehicle right and you can't
have the car
but you can have you know whatever you
can put anything up there
and you could sell it it's just crazy
it can be video it can be photos like
just anything digital anything
anything that you can turn digital all
right say the word we can do it do
whenever you want
yeah and another question that i had you
just said that you went into the
the arena to work out like what's your
workout program look like because dude
you just
you know it's pretty hard to believe
that i'm looking at a 62 year old guy
oh i appreciate that but don't remind me
i still tried a lot no like like i'm
lucky right because i own the team i'll
go to the arena tonight we have a game
and i'll get up shots first right so
i'll just go out there i'll be the first
one on the court before the guys come
and get warmed up for the game
and i'll just be up there getting up
buckets and you know depending on which
players come out i'll shoot with them
and then i'll go and get on the um
either the elliptical or the stairmaster
but every day i try to get an hour of
cardio in and then i lift some
um but you know i gave up with uh trying
to lift weights
a lot of weight because [ __ ] started
tearing so yeah you know now i just try
to do volume
yeah something warren buffett said that
you should break a sweat every single
day
yeah no matter what so so you're you're
in dallas
yeah that's where you live yeah with all
these people moving to texas
i just came up with the term i think the
texadus is that
already a term no i haven't heard that i
like that i can't believe that
i can't believe no one said that i was
thinking about it like you know well you
know what
you know put that as an nft detected and
i'll buy it that way i'll get the rights
to it
that's what's been going on there's a
texas with elon musk that's great
no that's a great line man that's uh
yeah
yeah definitely yeah and so i just
wonder you know i've seen some stuff
about like
don't california my texas you know like
people are
like how do you feel about about this
texas
you know there's texas which i love in
dallas i love
austin houston or cool but you know
there's
the texas politics which are really
[ __ ] up right and that's mostly
rural texas you know the further you get
from the city so there's like
there's like two texas right when you're
around the city
it's kind of like any city around the
country right any big city
but once you get outside it's it's
country you know and the politics are
different and i just avoid the politics
at that point because it just
it gets ugly but you know what in terms
of the text of this
bring it come to dallas you're gonna i
love dallas man i just love it here
that's great man you see you see you
avoid politics but uh
you know man the i had this
this sense i remembered like just kind
of seeing you in the news and i
the impression that i got was that you
kind of
trolled on donald trump yeah that's
right i went there
because i love to play with fire man you
know how crazy i am
i'm gonna tell you guys a secret about
a bonfire that i recently enjoyed with
my friends
while we were filming what really is a
secret project
it's not secret anymore because i'm
about to tell you it's
a project involving me being a
professional
tattoo artist yeah that's right and we
were
just throwing logs on the fire having
the best time who doesn't love being
around the fire
who doesn't love camping out you know i
love camping out
so get this this is the most exciting
thing for me
i am here to tell you about a traveling
portable fire pit that's right man it
comes from a company called
solo stove and they sent me one and i
was like man
this fits right in the cargo box
on the back of my rv with
all kinds of wood that i can burn like
i'm in went up a little trip with my bro
tommy over the weekend and we busted it
out
this thing's just so simple man and the
way that it's constructed it allows
air to flow through it prevents your
clothes from getting all stinky like a
campfire
it's got this little stand you put it on
which prevents
if you're on a wooden deck prevents it
from being damaged
and i'm telling you you never saw a
small amount of wood burn brighter it's
like how could this fire be so
big and red and dudes i want you
to try it because you know what no one
needs a reason to gather round the fire
and solo stove just took away any reason
not to and now you can get
ten dollars off when you use the promo
code stevo
at checkout so just go to
solostove.com
and remember you get ten dollars off
when you use the promo code steva one
more time use the promo code stever to
get ten dollars off at solo stove
and enjoy your fire pit
which you can bring anywhere backyards
like campsites whatever
you name it you're ready and you're
partying now
let's talk about trolling trump he
didn't just go after him with insults or
anything like that like and you gave him
always gave him credit where he felt
that he deserved credit and
and i just felt that it was really uh
you know like
pretty unbiased like objective like
criticism
you know but like i mean i don't know
like
your whole approach to politics i just
respect that because
i appreciate that you know because
because the way that you that you've uh
done it sort of you know i guess like
but that's what's [ __ ] up about
politics right because everybody
bandwagons it right they got their side
and they got their team right
i got one team right i've got two i got
my family and i got the country right
and it's just like you we can be honest
we can say you know what
republicans do something right
republicans do something wrong democrats
do something right
democrats do something wrong but
everybody so bandwagon that they don't
care what's good for the country and
that's what's [ __ ] up
right they'd rather they'd rather you
know [ __ ] everybody up than admit
they're wrong
and you know that's got to change
somehow i like that
my favorite thing i saw on your
wikipedia page was uh
whether it's a political party or
political affiliation but
independent yeah for sure that's
something like if it was up to me
i would get rid of all political parties
they're useless right it's not like
1892 where all you got is a telegraph to
tell people what you think right
it's just like we don't need parties you
don't need them for fundraising you
don't need them to communicate you don't
need them to
you know get people to to in groups and
community
you know why why do we have them still
exactly my dad
who uh my dad i grew up in a very
privileged upbringing my dad
uh was a corporate executive and
ultimately i think his best title was
president of nabisco
international damn that's pretty damn
big time too man
you gotta you know you i'm surprised you
got your teeth because you must have had
oreos
all day every day for sure
yeah and uh and pepsi and he was even a
tobacco his aberrationally good year was
when uh
the merger uh rjr
rj reynolds tobacco and uh and
they bought nabisco so that was dad's
best uh aberrationally good year um
what's impressive about your dad is that
he was learning portuguese as he's
flying into south america to give a
speech to everybody at pepsi in south
america like that's
that that's impressive that's impressive
he's an amazing man
my first i spoke my first words in
portuguese
because uh when i was six months old my
family moved to
brazil uh because my dad got the job of
uh
president of pepsi cola in all of brazil
that's pretty cool yeah super cool but
the reason i bring it up is because
dad has always identified as um
not just independent but an independent
thinker and and as it relates to
political parties he just puts it so
simply he says
why would i want to commit myself to an
answer to a question
that i haven't even heard yet amen your
dad is a smart man he's exactly right
100 right so uh so i love that now my
dad has also
steered me in different ways like
he he was a big fan of this guy peter
schiff and i don't expect anybody
listening to this podcast don't to know
but i know who peter ship is because of
the gold versus bitcoin [ __ ] right right
right and not even necessarily the i
think even before bitcoin because uh
you know they what peter schiff's thing
is and i can't
argue with it but you look at the way
that the the united states government
you know the whole economy of america is
basically a ponzi scheme where we're
just borrowing money
like we're borrowing money i disagree
with that i disagree with that are you
due
okay well yeah i'm very interested
aren't we just borrowing money
to pay the interest we're not even we're
not even trying to pay
what what what right so like when you
think about the first house you bought
the first car you bought right you
borrowed money you got that car loan
that was kind of freakly
freaky but you knew what assets you had
working for you i hope right
like you went to the bank and you said i
got this job right i'm smart
i got these things working i think i'm
going to increase my income right
and when you buy your house same thing
the house is worth this i think the
value is going to go
up right i got this job i feel confident
in my future
now you think about the united states of
america you know
we measure in gdp but gdp is not a good
measure of anything
and when you when you base things on a
certain benchmark
people always try to manipulate to get
to that benchmark so it's
become really worthless so if i ask
myself what are the assets of the united
states of america
right now we kind of petership included
tries to think of
our account of our printing money and
all that
as being how much income do you have
coming in and how much money you have
going out right and either they balance
or they don't and if they don't balance
then you're gonna have to pay
the the deficiency at some point right
you owe money and you're gonna have to
pay which is true
except if you just like when you got
that car in house you knew what your
assets were you knew what your
intellectual capital
we only use gdp and revenue right we
never take into account
what the assets of this country are the
physical land right
the intellectual capital you know we
created the internet
effectively right we built the internet
we dominate the internet
that's you know it helps gdp and it
helps
income and revenues but it's not really
accounted for as an asset
that you can borrow against right all
the smartness all the intellectual
capital we have around this country
that allows us to do more like with the
vaccine or do more with
um other things we don't take that into
account so if it was just you know if
mark cuban
was the one writing the checks right and
i would look at it and say okay what
assets do we have
that we have value for now there is
there a limit yeah there's potentially a
limit
but i think that we're able to get such
a great return off of those assets
because
we're such an entrepreneurial country
we're always coming up with new [ __ ]
that we didn't think we'd be able to
come up with
always and that creates new ways to
generate income
and tax revenue and opportunity in this
country
that's that makes us unique you know
that's what makes the u.s really unique
over
any other country joe biden told this
said this to me and i still you know i
still texted us from you and i stole
this from joe biden
he said mark i've been around the world
and the one thing that separates us is
we're a country of entrepreneurs we're
always thinking of new things we're
always trying to
invent new ways to change the future
quantum computing
all this stuff is all us-based you know
can you do can you
print money right you know borrow money
against that future
if it creates a better life for people
now and
if you're printing money to feed kids to
put them in better schools
aren't you really just improving the
entrepreneurial future that we have so
that
that american exceptionalism is even
more exceptional
and so that's the way i look at it you
know and you know
as long as you don't get into hyper you
know you don't start really pushing
inflation
and where i changed my mind in this is i
always thought like everybody that if
you just kept on printing money
inflation was going to go nuts right
but we haven't seen that and they're
always about to say it's about to go
nuts well if it starts to go nuts you
raise interest rates inflation goes down
and we'll reevaluate
but right now we just innovate like
[ __ ] in this country
there's you know when you start thinking
about now you got precision medicine you
got
a.i that we lead in you got you know
what else you've got all the computer
vision
you know all all these different things
advanced technologies
quantum computing that we don't even
account for
when we look at our balance sheet for
the united states of america
right so to me i'm bullish you know and
i'm like let's give this [ __ ] a chance
we don't need to raise taxes right now
let's just see how this experiment we're
in the middle of plays out
i think my dad would would chime in and
say but we also don't account for
unfunded liabilities
but we do because we know we're there
right we know they're there
now you can argue that there's
derivatives of derivatives of
derivatives like warren buffett says
you know that that's a time bomb that
those are weapons of mass destruction
but those are weapons of mass
destruction because we don't account for
them correctly
but in terms of unfunded liabilities
like social security or that's not
medicare um social security right and
other things that we don't even account
for at all right as long as we know
they're there
right then because any company like when
your dad was at nabisco i'm sure they
had debt against the balance sheet and
they just had to out innovate their
competitors
right and when they stopped being able
to out innovate they sold
you know and then rjr [ __ ] it all up
because they were just trying to get
more people to smoke and then they try
to get into other [ __ ] but
but you get my point right you can out
innovate your debt levels
and like with you right you keep on
innovating and coming up with new ways
right 10 years ago you weren't thinking
you know what i'm going to be doing this
wild ride
podcast and i'm going to continue doing
that right right having conversations
about
nfts that i'm about to sell right as
long as you
innovate right that's the key it's when
we stop innovation then we're [ __ ]
that's when we can't pay our debts
that's when we can't grow into it
so are are you bullish on everything
with the american economy right now real
estate
bitcoin or do you when interest rates
are low
anything that can appreciate does
appreciate right so
that's the key so the key is as long as
we're doing productive things
like if if if it's you know stevo
and the wild ride inc then
you guys can find a way to invest to
make more than two percent
on your money and that's that's what
it's like america
inc can invest and make more than two
percent than the interest rates we're
charging right now
and do it with something productive you
know that that kind of stuff
i think that's why i'm bullish now if
you know
we're all wrong on inflation or i'm
wrong in inflation and
the people who are you know think it
inflation's inevitable are right
then that's a different ball game and
we'll find out but i don't think
see when you're in the middle of
something like when you start the wild
ride right
you don't know what's going to happen
you're just an entrepreneur you've been
an entrepreneur most your life right
and you have that fear going in to
everything and all those new things all
those new ideas
but you can't just stop you know after
one try or two tries or three tries and
we've got this experiment where
basically because of the pandemic we're
just printing money left and right
and then we did another stimulus another
two trillion printing money left and
right
now we got the the um
the um next two trillion that we're
going to be spending 2.4
yeah everything right um all these
upgrades everywhere
like let's just see how it plays out
let's not see where i think where
biden's [ __ ] up is that not that he's
doing it for infrastructure
but that he's looking at raising track
taxes for it
right because that's how you [ __ ] up the
new business right that's how you [ __ ]
up this great experiment we're in the
middle of
because you got to let it play out you
can't because the only thing we know
about economists
is that they're all [ __ ] wrong all
the time right and they stick to their
guns no matter what so let's just see
what happens and play it out
right yeah peter schiff hasn't been
wrong for 20 years leadership has never
admitted that he was wrong ever
right so for somebody for somebody new
like me
wanting to buy a house i mean it's so
crazy right now would you wait or would
you
would you wait i mean people are like no
it's going to keep going up i mean what
do you do
no it could go back down but you got
it's got to be a house you can live in
that you'd otherwise have to pay rent
for the same amount because rents are
going up too
and so what i would do is see what i can
afford
rent versus buying right if they're
about the same then i would buy
but then part two to that i'd be
knocking on the door of the mayor or
whoever
saying you got to change zoning loss
because what's [ __ ] up a lot of this
is that you can't build [ __ ] where you
want to build it you got to keep on
moving further and further and further
out into the suburbs and the boonies
whereas you know because of the pandemic
if
you got all these office buildings that
aren't going to be filled with
companies anymore why not change zoning
laws so you could take
this floor and turn it into apartments
yeah or condos
i heard that they might start doing that
i hope so right because it's smart to do
it
so you take all this under utilized
space because people aren't going to be
moving back in the offices anymore and
you want to revitalize downtown
and just turn them into condos why not
you know but that increases the supply
because one of the reasons it's low
interest rates
and the fact that you can't people
they're not building houses where people
want to buy them
yeah ma'am okay so
what about the movie theaters right you
you're
you're uh i wrote one more yeah we sold
ours are the landmarks
landmark cinemas when did you sell it
two
three years ago now oh my god oh wow
well done holy smokes dude wow what an
into that
sometimes you're lucky oh my god you
seem to be
lucky a lot of the time um what uh
didn't did magnolia go with that you
sold them together we still have
magnolia
um and so we're still doing distribution
of other people's movies we're not
really
producing our own anymore i found you
know a quick story like
the first movie i ever produced was i
got this i got an email from was it
i'm sorry the loose change was one that
i read about the word
no no no no i never did anything with
that okay okay i never did anything with
that i just
yeah that i talked to charlie sheen
about that but nothing happened but
this is 2004 i get an email from this
dude alex gibney who'd never really done
anything
okay oscar guy yeah so he sends me an
email just cold email says i got all
this video from
enron and i emailed him back and i'm
like do you own the rights to all the
video he goes yeah 100
exclusive rights i'm like you want to do
a documentary he goes yeah i go how much
what's the budget go 770
000 i'm like let's do it 12 minutes i
green lit this movie goes on to become
enron the smartest guys in the room
because one of the top 10 grossing
documentaries at the time
gets nominated for an academy award i'm
thinking this shit's easy
right then my partner todd wagner comes
to me he goes george clooney's got this
black and white movie
about um the 1950s and the communist
scare
and it's going to be a movie called good
night and good luck
and it's 4 million from us 4 million
from this other company
i think we should do it i'm like great
let's do it kills it right
gets nominated for six academy awards
with george clooney and so i'm like
this shit's easy we didn't win any right
but i'm like we're i'm having
oscars parties i'm showing everywhere
and i'm like
i'm just killing the game you haven't
heard a movie we've done up done
since and so we just like that's him
that i've heard of all kinds of movies
whenever i'm watching
um whenever i sit down to watch a movie
and it starts with that magnolia
like yeah well those are the ones we
distribute not the ones that we create
oh gotcha
because whenever i see it i'm like yes
and i had no idea what they were
involved
you know i honestly feel like wow like
they've never failed me magnolia
magnolia comes on i'm like oh dude this
is great i'm ready
yeah yeah aiming bowls eamon bowles is
the guy in charge and he is
really really good he's got great taste
my taste is i found out the hard way
sucks
right so i let it all go there no more
producing movies
so all those movies that didn't work out
couldn't you make them nfts and sell
them
i thought okay so it's so funny you say
that right oh
so i'll buy it for 25 bucks i emailed
amen a couple of weeks ago and i'm like
okay i know we've sold it to hulu and
sold rights off around the world
are there any that were like so bad that
we just couldn't sell them and we owned
all the rights but we didn't have any
didn't have any
uh okay so i i have a few notes here and
and uh from you i i put in the top right
corner
i wrote listen
okay let me tell you a story on that
right
we're rolling boy we're wrong so
obviously i like to talk and i'm
i'm an interrupter right my my kids my
parents my friends just would crush me
on that ship
and so i got this job out of college
that i didn't last very long and they
didn't like me very much
and this guy who was trying to be my
mentor larry manah
he goes son i just want to tell you this
i'm like 22.
he goes i'm going to give you a tool
that you can use because you need this
because you don't listen he goes every
time you go into a meeting i want you to
have a notepad
and the minute you sit down i want you
to write the word
listen right there on your notepad
because
right there in the corner right all the
time yeah
no lie if you go back over the last
40 years now that i've been going into
meetings and taking notes
i write listen first thing that's cool
speaking of jobs out of college i i saw
that you were a
disco instructor yeah baby
is that that's cool you tell me if this
is cool being paid 25
an hour when you're in college should go
to sorority houses and teach girls how
to dance
that's a pretty good game it's pretty
good opener right there yo if you got
any openings i'll still take that job
that's great man that's that's so good
another thing i decided to say i really
enjoyed is that
i'm a ready fire aim guy
same thing it's just like i know i know
what i'm good at and i know what i suck
at
and like i'm bigger picture and i always
need to partner with somebody who's anal
somebody who deals with the details and
so todd wagner martin wood
all these partners i've had over the
years i got to do it because otherwise
my shit's all over the place because i
like to think
you know big and what's next and how
we're going to change the game
and then you know i forget i gotta deal
with the contracts and
people and this and that so yeah i'm not
really good at the details i think that
that so
perfectly sums up my relationship with
scott here scott's uh
he's my my dot the eyes cross the t's
like
super like focused on making sure that
that everything's getting done and i'm
just
wow all over the place i got it right
well yeah
because that's the way your brain works
well then that's what he's good at and
that's what i'm good at and that's
you know the more that i can do that the
more i let him be him and that's that's
my job
amen man that's what makes a good
partnership that's what makes for good
business and people don't realize that
like they start a company
and they're like okay i'm gonna get
somebody with this this this and they
don't realize
that's who they are right you gotta you
got
the number one of the number one traits
of being an entrepreneur is you gotta be
self-aware
you gotta know what you're good at you
gotta know what you suck at because
there's always someone trying to kick
your ass and put you out of business
and if you can't figure it out they'll
figure it out for you
yeah what i liked about you is that
you're probably the 51st guest that
we've had and
you're probably the only one that's come
in earlier
than the time that we gave them and
uh and what's crazy about that is like i
can count on one hand how many times
i've been late in my entire life it just
pains me to be 10 minutes early
because i feel like that's too late you
know and so
like my question to you is like what
happens if you have somebody coming in
for a job interview
and they're on time or a minute late are
they done
no matter what immediately nah nah just
depends on the job first of all
i'm so bad at interviewing i don't
interview people at all and i haven't
for years because i am the worst because
like i'm a sales guy at heart an
entrepreneur at heart so i'm like
selling them on the job right as opposed
to them selling me
and so it's awful but yeah i'm like
i was early for this one but it was just
lucky okay
i was just curious about that i'm not
gonna lie she's gotta i'm
i'm i'm late all the time not not like
nasty late but and i try to get there
early especially now and it's easier now
because of zoom
right but um yeah yeah
i'm that guy who's three four five
minutes late and just saying oops sorry
and but i can do that now because no
one's going to say [ __ ] you to me
anymore
that's so great yeah and i think that um
with uh
it's what you bring to the table too you
know like yeah but if you're four
minutes late
and you're like i'm like oh my god this
guy's gonna be late on like
some important thing understood but then
like they say there's
my dynamic with you and you're like 100
punctual everything like
the responsive and then i got paul
briskey the gorgeous guy at the front of
the van
right and and paul is he's like more the
producer of my content the editor
he's got this creative ability to just
to tell stories with the videos that we
make
which is just unmatched so paul's got me
by the balls because i can't replace him
you know i just i can't replace him so
so
so when paul like as soon as he leaves
and he's not like
physically he punches the clock out and
then you don't hear from him like
he's the worst at responding to text and
it drives scott and i nuts like what the
[ __ ] but i'm like
god i wish paul would [ __ ] you know
exist when he's not
actually working but he's just doing his
thing and who knows what that is
but when he shows up he's just so
irreplaceable he's so good at his job
that like you know you gotta paul you do
the
i job maybe let's talk no i just
i try to have very strong healthy work
boundaries but perhaps
i mean dude i respect it no you're
absolutely in the right
because i've had jobs before where like
i i leave the office then i'm getting
calls all night i'm answering emails all
night
and that's why when i started working
with you steve i was like i need because
that
it just becomes unsustainable it's even
like i was down to answer emails at 10
at night or whatever because it was fun
but it's not sustainable and eventually
gets sick of it so when i started this
job i was like i need
really strict boundaries and like it's
up to me to make those boundaries like
no one's going to
enforce them oh you're getting [ __ ] done
right oh he's the best he yeah he's the
best that's all that matters right
you're getting it done your boss thinks
you're the best your two houses think
you're the best
[ __ ] the rest right i mean yeah cause
just cause his mind's working like that
doesn't mean you know right he's getting
it done
yeah and that's the first time i've ever
even brought it up
no i know that's
i didn't bring it up to put you on blast
it's just to to scott's point
says there's some people who are gonna
show up late to the interview
but you absolutely have to [ __ ] hire
them because they bring something else
to the table that's irreplaceable
well you know what it all comes down to
this there's two types of people that
you partner with or work with those who
create stress
and those who reduce your stress and if
they reduce your stress you'll do
anything to keep them if they create
stress you'll do you'll find
some way to get rid of them but they're
always the ones that think that they
save you all the hassle right
the people you know the people who
reduce your stress like gorgeous
you know he's cool with it all and
you're cool with it because he gets [ __ ]
done
oh he's the best and scott yeah there's
something i wanted to tell you about
that said
scott's scott uh came with me on tour
um he started with my comedy tour in
2014.
just kind of as a bro you know if if i
might as well just be i'll be honest
here
i i was uh addressing issues with
with sexual acting out i was like you
know what i'm about to become 40
and i don't want to be this this
promiscuous pathetic guy
trying to chase taylor that's not the
road to happiness i said
i said if i'm going to be happy i need
to learn how to have a healthy
relationship
and so i had to address these issues and
and scott came on the road as
as my [ __ ] blocker you know because
after
after all my shows and i'm doing the
meet and greet and selling my merch
like just how i say hey man just be
there to help me like
stay on this path and thank god i stayed
on the path because now i have i'm
engaged i've got a great relationship
and it's all because of that but when
scott came on the road
he looks at what what i've got i've got
my my book i'm a new york times
best-selling author i've got my
my book and i sell it i'd sign it for
everybody after the shows
and i had t-shirts and that was it scott
says all you have is books and t-shirts
and you don't you don't even uh have
credit card swiper
it's like oh god man we got it so next
thing you know scotch is revolutionizes
my my touring
merch and we went from three products to
probably like
40 skus ladies and gentlemen let's make
that
41 skus because we are in the business
of skateboards and i am autographing
every single one of them
i mean this one you just can't keep it
in stock for very long
i'm telling you right now they are
available and if you haul ass to
stevo.com
you can get yourself one of these
autographed skateboards man
and dude skateboards are tough to come
by since the pandemic
man but we got them not for long grab
yourself one
and let's talk business you know we have
a hot sauce business that's top three on
amazon right now
damn yeah we have you want a job
yeah no but for real like for real like
you guys you're going to have to start
learning about nfts because tickets are
going to turn into nfts and collectibles
right because i bought you know i went
to you know when things open back up
today people aren't just going to want a
ticket where like
now you got a stub like you put it up on
your court border ship right
now you're going to want that digital
collectible to say yeah i was at sivo
and
you know i have this like lazy.com so if
you want to see my nfts it's lazy.com
cuban but yeah i want to post you know
to show everybody my nfts where um
all the shows i've been to all the steve
oh and you know
who's been to the most shows who's got
it in the nfts in their wallet then you
get yada yada
it's going to change all touring all
shows
all right well we're going to have to do
that yeah but uh over over the years so
scott and i
we've just traveled the world over and
over and over for
for what like uh seven eight years seven
years now and um
the whole time every meal it's like if
if i don't have
hot sauce i have this i have what i call
a condiment disorder
you know i gotta like just you know food
is just a vehicle for shoveling
condiments
like you want some french fries with
your ketchup right and and hot sauce is
particularly important and so scott says
to me and
one point says man dude you love hot
toast so much you gotta have your own
hot sauce brand
and he just he did this with so many
products you love your sunglasses so
much you gotta have sunglasses
but the hot sauce that we came out with
which is uh you know it bounces around
it goes up to number three on amazon
sometimes
and and the name of it is stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
and because of course
but right and i remember when i ran that
by my dad my dad said well that's about
the dumbest thing i've ever heard
because you've really limited yourself
of what marketplaces you can be in you
know
no store is going to put that on the
shelves but
i view it totally differently because uh
there's so much hot sauce out there to
compete with what makes our brand
do well is that people see it and it's
it's a little cartoon image of me on the
bottle with a
stick of dynamite up my butt and uh you
know and it's hilarious says stevo's hot
toss for people
i agree with you i agree with you you
got to stand out because there's so
many hot sauces so many condiments right
you've got to have something that gives
people a reason to talk about it
and it becomes like when they have it at
their house people want to talk about it
and see what it is it's a great stocking
stuffer
yeah of course yeah of course impulse
buy at the counter it's like how can you
go wrong
yeah dude and um so i said
you know i've got i got a couple more
things i wanted to tell you that for
again just what an honor man this is i i
couldn't when i found out that we got
mark cuban i don't want to kiss your
brother
whatever whatever i was like when i got
the email like stevo wants to talk to me
and
i'm like that's so [ __ ] cool
seriously it's just like
you know because we don't run in the
same circle so it's just like something
different
dude i gotta isolate that little sound
bite right there and
just yeah make an nft out of it yeah
out of it unbelievable no texas is the
nft
right so so i uh you know i did a fair
amount of research i wanted to come in
prepared
and um kind of tell you out of the out
of all of the
the videos that i watched and everything
it was really enjoyable
to to do this research the toughest
thing
that was just [ __ ] dealing with the
the fox news interviews what a nightmare
what a [ __ ] i mean i hate to alienate
anybody with like you know
like the political stuff but i just got
to say that
it was really difficult to sit through
that eight minutes with sean hannity
they were fun though they were fun
because it was
fun right because it's easy to talk to
something you know you're cool right
that's cool right you know prep you know
gorgeous maybe not
but you know it's easy just to shoot the
[ __ ] with somebody like but when you get
to somebody you disagree with
right right and trying to like win that
little eight minute battle because you
know what it's like when you do
interviews you got no idea what's coming
at you
and you know it's just like a challenge
to to come through on it
so it was fun i just it's like i say it
was difficult to watch because i just
felt that it was
really just kind of oh it was like fed
up every which way right she was trying
to come at me
just yeah it was [ __ ] but you know
that's the way those things are and i
just i just like the challenge
right yeah i mean i feel like all news
outlets are biased one way or another is
there any like
news source that you get your news from
that's pretty like centrist
um i mean honestly since the election
i've like only listened to music like i
used to always have cnn then i turned to
fox some just to hear what's going on
and hear the other side but now it's
just like [ __ ] i mean
you know at least at least i know with
biden
if i disagree with them there there's a
way to
disagree right and somebody's going to
have a legitimate discussion with you
whereas before it was just like no one
wanted to deal with facts or this or
that it was all emotional right
but you know in terms of where i get
news like i'll do ap
and reuters um really as my main news
sources
um and then if there's there's actually
a site called
mimeo random m-e-m-e-o
random um i think that's how you spell
it and they just list
they aggregate different news stories
from different sites
and so i'll just glance through there to
see if there's anything interesting to
me and if not
you know i get an email from reuters an
email from ap i'll glance at them but
now
you know the vaccine like we went from
sucking at covid and being like one of
the world's worst
to like okay you know we're starting to
have some confidence and you know
i think we're getting this right we're
number of vaccines per day people are
freaking out less
people aren't yelling at their families
as much you're not you know running into
people that you think are gonna
pound you with a bat because you
disagree with them so like it's like i
don't need to deal with that [ __ ]
anymore and
like i didn't like politics like
honestly
for non-presidential elections i always
voted for the person i thought would do
the least
because i never you know i'm not a fan
of politicians generally
it was only when trump got involved that
and because i've known him for so long
that i kind of said okay i got to say
something right
and uh wait wait what's your
relationship with trump now
like i i saw a pretty recent interview
you said that he called you up randomly
it sounded like that wasn't very long
ago
now that was like october um this past
october i guess
no no it would have been march it was
last march and
he started asking me because it was
right before we were going back
right when the nba season was closing
down and he was asking me about players
and
who's you know how the nba is going and
this and that and i'm like
why did he call me to call me then he
invited me to dinner
and knowing donald trump he doesn't just
invite someone to dinner just to chit
chat like this right
and so i knew he was setting me up for
something for a photo op or something
where he wanted me to
just come out and say that i enjoyed
meeting him or this or that
and so i never took him up on it right
okay
i think that when when i heard you say
that since the election you're just
listening to music
is it is it safe to say that's because
once biden became the president
now like tv is just not as fun
anymore you know yeah that has a lot to
do with it for sure right you didn't
saturday there's always a tweet saturday
live was so great when trump was the
president it was just
and now like it's not it's like alec
baldwin has got to worry about where his
wife is from
as opposed to donald trump right
everything changed everybody's
everything
right and the same goes for i heard that
all the ratings on all the news channels
have just pretty yeah um
and uh okay except for like if i see
something
on the news about like the the
possibility of a trump
criminal you know you know if
something's gonna happen like you can't
throw a former president in jail so i
don't think he's going to jail
but i think maybe his kids who knows
what's going to happen there
but you know all these lawsuits that got
put off because he was president
they're all coming back and his brand is
just for [ __ ] now
so his businesses have got to be getting
crushed
and so he's got to be freaking out
because he's not making any money
and he his businesses are probably
losing money
i mean and he's paying for all these
lawsuits oh my god i i
wouldn't want to be him for sure and
then on top of that all the hundreds of
millions of dollars of debt that's
coming due in the next
couple years yeah no he's not in a good
financial position at all
because remember he had to report all
his cash and presuming he's not lying
too much about how much cash he had
he ain't got enough right so he's got to
either particularly if he's funding
losses for his companies and so
he's going to have to sell stuff and and
it's going to be interesting to see what
happens
wow yeah maybe instead of the trump
tower in vegas can be the cuban tower
you know i i actually have an apartment
in one of his buildings in new york
and i bought it in like 1999 after i
sold my company and
and then it was okay right i was just it
was brand new building and i'm like this
is cool
i didn't mind it being trump but once he
got elected you could just see the whole
like the people at the front desk would
be like this all the time
that means even staying there is
probably just so political at that point
you know
right yeah do you mind if i ask you uh
do you have a morning routine that you
do every day do you wake up at the same
time do you
are there certain things that you have
to do every day or kind of yeah
i mean like first thing i do um after
you know with my kids are 11 14 and 17
so they're still getting off to school
and stuff and so my wife does most of
that so i can't take credit
but you know trying to get get them off
um and then i just go
dig into emails like i try to do as much
as i can via email because it becomes a
tickler file for me
anything unread the minute my eyes open
up like i literally want
you know i'll get back in bed and i'll
just start rolling through these emails
so i can get down to under 40
unread which is a lot of emails i got to
go through
and then from there i got to go get
tested because i get to get tested for
the mavs every day so i can go to the
games
and then from there i'll come back and
you know either you know do calls do
interviews
do my email some more then i'll get a
workout in either before the game
um watch the game and then if i didn't
get my workout in
before the game then afterwards i'll get
my workout in
yeah man you got to get a workout in
every day
got to where i feel like something's
[ __ ] up right and um
i mean dude it's incredible how hands-on
you are just in the process of of
booking this interview
i couldn't even believe i was like wait
a second is that mark cuban on the email
like like this they actually went to you
and yeah of course yeah why would it and
it's just easier
right you know instead of someone coming
to you and saying mark what do you think
about this this and this
i mean i'm just like oh steve oh cool i
just reply add my assistant on to it
you know book it yeah it's gone it went
the other way around normally it would
go
you go to the rep and then then yeah but
but it was uh
there was mark himself he said oh yeah
hell yeah let's do it and he says like
you know so-and-so will set it up so i
mean
that was probably yeah bam i mean
because i gotta get on to the next one
right that's so good and uh i mean yeah
i saw you with uh with kevin hart like
that was that a lot of fun
i didn't do it it never happened never
happened yeah never happened
then the ice bath the ice bath one oh
yeah oh the
coldest balls were supposed to do
something else that didn't have with
shark tank um
yeah no that was fun kevin's awesome man
yeah um
i mean the bad thing was i thought i was
getting in shape that's one of the
reasons i'm working on an hour every day
and then i saw that i'm like
you [ __ ] fat ass you thought
you were in state
he probably lost half his viewership
because i had my shirt off
i don't know about all that but uh but
the the the
ice bath video with with kevin hart ran
for about
four minutes and something on on youtube
but
yeah i just know production i know it
always takes a lot longer than
oh yeah how long were you actually in
the ice bath
um probably 60 plus minutes holy [ __ ]
60 minutes yeah a lot of cutting yeah i
know that's that's the nature of the
beast
but yeah it's like shark tank right
right friday nights on abc
um like when we shoot those things the
deals come in
and they might go like the shitty ones
are 20 minutes and they cut them down to
10.
but the intense ones where we're all
interested or there's something we
really care about
those can go 60 to 90 minutes and the
longest one's been two and a half hours
and then they'll edit those down to 10
to 14 minutes so yeah
it's all editing it's just like gorgeous
earns his money right
yeah there you go give me a job and
gorgeous said he wanted to ask
like man i wonder why mark cuban does
shark tank it's got to be a big
time invent you know a big time
commitment it's gotta be and i thought
man
you know like i don't see it that way at
all i think number one shark tank's got
to be a blast
yeah it is fun and number two you know i
read that there's something in the
neighborhood of like 20 million dollars
that you've actually invested in deals
that came through shark tank
and i'm i'm guessing that the return on
that 20 million dollars
has got to be like billions you gotta at
least no
it's not as much as you think because a
lot of them were dumb right
so i mean i i do the show because it
sends a great message that
the american dream is alive and well i
love you guys are living it
i'm living it right and a lot of people
are down on that like it can't happen
anymore
and and i just don't agree with that a
lot of people it's tough right
they come from circumstances where you
know they got to jump a lot higher than
somebody else
in order to get to the same spot but you
know by doing the show
you see a lot of those entrepreneurs
come up that and they're standing there
on the carpet you hear their story and
just struggles you know and and
challenges and
being able to send that message to the
entire country and it's showing around
the world
that in this country the american dream
is alive and well and people from
hard circumstances have a chance and can
make it
um that's why i do the show and so
there's times like
there's a way i invest outside the show
but inside the show if it sends a good
message and i want to just help the
company
then i'll do something so the returns
aren't as good as the otherwise maybe
but
i'm still up i've made some money off
still up and and uh i think this
this is this is all i got you know left
but i think that
out of the research i did for you if
there was one word
that really uh you know
that i now associate with you it would
be hedging
like hedging from the very beginning of
your career
and hedging with the yahoo money like
all the way through now even with with
nfts
and and everything hedging hedging
hedging well i mean it's just more like
don't get greedy right like when i had a
b next to my name it was like
there were people saying well it could
go up you could go i'm like how much
[ __ ] money do i need right i'd
rather keep it
and not lose it so i hedge right and
when something's going really really
well
i like to let it ride but i want to
protect that downside so i hedged
but um yeah i mean you know
pigs get fat hogs get slaughtered you
know you gotta you gotta realize that
when
you're doing well enjoy the moment enjoy
it you don't
because getting greedy is what typically
gets you in trouble for sure
and and i think that uh on the topic of
hedging
yeah i would i just my dad i gotta just
ask
where are you at with precious metals
like i know you like
metal okay let's let's only talk gold
gold is [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's fighting awards with my
dad
gold is [ __ ] right look gold has no
intrinsic value outside of some
manufacturing applications
ask your dad do we really need gold
jewelry
anybody here's what my dad's going to
say is that you can print money you can
you know you can but you can't print
gold it's it's it's
a it's in a finite yeah like
it's it's there's a limit to you can't
add to it so
i can't i can't print steaks i can't
print eggplant parmesan i can't print
you know water bottles
right i can't print stevo hot sauce
you know that doesn't make it a currency
or a hedge you know
and there's and i don't think bitcoin is
a hedge either
they're completely disassociated two
different worlds
like if everything went to hell in a
handbasket and you're walking around
with a bar of gold you know what's going
to happen
someone's going to beat the [ __ ] out of
you or shoot your ass and take your bar
of gold
and use it for a doorstop because
you know you what are you going to do
with it it's just like gold jewelry is
just a narrative that says
gold is more valuable now there's
properties of gold right it doesn't
you know it retains its color and yada
yada right so it can look nicer than
some other precious metals
but i mean it's not a hedge to
anything the only reason your dad thinks
it's a hedge is because he got
sold that that [ __ ] [ __ ] is a
hedge peter's shift got through to him
yeah if we got rid of all the gold and
gold in fort knox
nothing would change all right so if
you're up on gold right now you might as
well just sell it right is that what
yeah i mean i'd rather have it
like i've never really owned gold i've
traded it now and then i've
i've shorted it um because i think it's
just crazy to own gold as as
a hedge um but i'd rather own bitcoin at
least there's algorithmic scarcity and
it's easy
to trade like with gold if you actually
have to take delivery of that gold bar
and you have twenty thousand dollars
worth of gold how the [ __ ] you gonna
sell it to somebody for
anything it's gonna be yo stevo can i
have some of
plant parmesan and some bananas here's
my gold you know and it's just like
right here's my whale barrel what are
you gonna do
you know how are you gonna trade with
the world with a wear
wheelbarrow short full of gold it's
useless
useless in fact with gold you have to do
it as commodities
which is just digital which is just
trying
is what bitcoin is better at now bitcoin
it you know it's just a store of value
like anything else it's worth what
somebody will pay for it
but i think it's a better version of
gold than gold so
bitcoin not gold efts not the gold
certificates
i'd rather have bitcoin because if
things start to go crazy
you can use bitcoin and exchange value
digitally and do that around the world
you can
with gold you can deal with commodities
and you can deal with derivatives
but you can't ever deal with the actual
gold itself no one ever takes delivery
of it
right but you can actually you know who
who do you know that
the people that own gold are the people
that see um
who's that old-school actor talking
about gold coins
you know on all the late-night
commercials
henry winkler does that maybe yeah all
that [ __ ] right
it's just like there's just no real
intrinsic value other than manufacturing
applications
and you can argue about jewelry but with
bitcoin it doesn't pretend to have
the same type of value bitcoins
intrinsic value is that it's a platform
that is friction free to exchange if you
have bitcoin
and i have bitcoin i can buy a tesla by
just you know
sending my bitcoin from to elon's
bitcoin
bitcoin wallet and he sends me my tesla
so much easier if i wanted to buy a
tesla with gold it ain't happening
well do you like tesla yeah
yeah as a stock that's different but i
like the cars okay
i have money i have a a tesla and i have
stock and tesla so where did i go wrong
there
you didn't go wrong anywhere i mean look
the stock went too high and then it
comes back and then
you know there'll be more hype when new
versions come out and people talk about
it
it's just you know when you get into a
hype stock it goes up and it's going to
come down
just like bitcoin goes up and comes down
it's going to be volatile that's just
part of the deal
yeah and you know if you believe in what
elon's doing with batteries and
cars and you know um yeah solar cars
driving themselves
yeah and i believe that's part of the
future yeah
how how how uh bullish are you on like
self-driving cars like how near in the
future does that
it's probably so here's the thing for
self-driving cars and i've said this to
the city of dallas i said
the best way to get self-driving cars it
has nothing to do really with the cars
it has everything to do with what we do
in cities
like if you when you go to vegas and you
go to the strip you never cross the
street
right you always go over you know you're
a dead person if you try to cross the
street
and so people don't trust self-driving
cars now if all the walkways in a city
downtown
went over the street like in vegas in
the strip
people could do self-driving cars all
day long because you're not worried
about them running somebody over
and you can do the same thing with
deliveries you can do the same thing
with self-driving trucks right
you know if we designed um communities
where
you know the houses were designed so a
little robot got dropped you know
climbs out of the back of a self-driving
truck and you have a little port
you have a little um path that goes to
your refrigerator in the back of your
house
and it just stuffs [ __ ] in there from
amazon all the time or whatever
that's the stuff that needs to change
it's not even the technology for the
self-driving cars you gotta get
peop rather than trying to upgrade the
self-driving cars you gotta get people
in the friction
out of the way and that's when it
happens so tell me how far i am off of
this is that i heard that
when you're when you're logging in
online somewhere and it says you know
are you a robot
click the sidewalks click to this it
already knows you're not a robot by the
very fact that you're moving the mouse
the the fact that you're clicking on
crosswalks it's teaching the ai
computer on how to recognize certain
things yes and no so it's not because
you move the mouse because you can fake
that
but what it's doing those captchas
they're um they're
teach they're labeling um
photos for computer vision so for
computer vision to work
it's got to have labeled data and the
more labeled data it has to be able to
know what's a car what's a bike what's a
tree
right then the better and more efficient
it is in
in identifying things using computer
vision
and so they're using people to label
data to make their models smarter
jesus dude so 2025 we're going to have
automated big rigs driving across the
united states
the only problem is the last three miles
once you get into the inner cities right
of navigation you know what
if you did the equivalent of bike lanes
on the inter on interstates so that they
were for self-driving trucks
[ __ ] would change so quick and be so
much easier right it would just go in
there and just go straight
and then you know then you got to deal
with getting off the highway but then
you'd have somebody
pop on instead of having someone drive
you know 20 straight hours to go from
point a to point b or city a to city b
you just have the [ __ ] waiting
there and it'll be like the indie races
right you know when they're
running with the cars and changing
everything they'll just jump in there
right and then drive the car the rest of
the way the last three miles
so yeah there's a lot of things that can
change so hopefully this infrastructure
bill is smart enough to recognize that
wow well dude i i can't thank you enough
is there anything that that we can
direct people to like uh yeah sure i
mean i'm happy to hype
um for the nfts right if you're into nfp
i just launched a site three weeks ago
called lazy.com
and what it is it allows you to have
your own personal
gallery of your nfts so when i when you
get the texadus
stevo nft you can you present it proudly
and it has a
shortened url so if you want to check
out my nfts it's lazy.com
mcuben and if you want to just see all
these companies shark tank and
everything just go to mark cuban.com
and of course watch shark tank friday
nights on abc because that's where i do
my best [ __ ]
it's fantastic man i'm such a fan of
shark tank yeah
it's uh my dad too all right brother
well hey man
i just can't thank you enough and uh
this really was a treat dude i
enjoyed it was fun man you guys are
awesome i i really enjoyed it you know
thank you yeah you guys just went with
it had fun so it really was a lot of fun
hell yeah i appreciate you brother man
and go mavs
yes sir yes sir this is luck tonight all
right guys if i can do anything for
y'all just holler
yeah for sure appreciate you brother
appreciate it thank you guys
later mark peace thanks thanks gorgeous
yeah you're welcome
how [ __ ] cool was that and
how cool are you for sticking around to
the very end
i like to make it special for you guys i
don't always do that great of a job but
this week man
what a special [ __ ] podcast that was
and i've got some sad news that
after we got done i googled texadus and
even though i came up with it on my own
a lot of other people did too
so what are you gonna do man i am
getting into the nft business though at
mark cuban's suggestion i have
already found what i believe to be a
broker
and a gallery and i'm figuring it out
i've picked my first
asset which i'm going to put on sale is
an nft and it is a racy one okay
plus we're having it animated making it
even more racy
but uh here you know i've told you guys
about my pro model skateboard so
let's see what i got on this thing i'm
gonna [ __ ] play a little game of
hey do a kick flip
ah i'm gonna be heartbroken if i don't
get it but i'm gonna live by whatever
happens win lose or draw man
and [ __ ] here goes
that was [ __ ] okay
okay here we go i like facing this way
better
you bastard this does
lend credibility to [ __ ] like
i don't know how hard i'm working as a
pro skater
that's it
that's just how hard skating is okay
and when you see my video about becoming
a pro skateboarder now you're gonna
actually appreciate
how much effort i put into that video
god i worked my ass off all right
thank you guys for watching